growing number of Americans believe
children do not need vaccinations
despite overwhelming scientific evidence
that vaccines do in fact prevent disease
a new Gallup poll finds 84 percent of
Americans say it is extremely or very
important that parents vaccinate their
children but that is down 10 percent
from 2001 and it comes as several states
are debating laws to limit on vaccinated
children's access to schools meg Oliver
is here with more so made good morning
what's being done to make sure these
kids are in fact vaccinated Toni good
morning a controversial bill collapsed
this week in New Jersey that would have
removed religious exemptions to vaccines
and potentially forced parents to put
unvaccinated kids into private school or
home school some parents say they're
glad the bill hasn't passed but the
science community says vaccines are safe
and can save lives this was the scene
outside New Jersey State Capitol Monday
thousands of people protesting as
lawmakers debated parents rights to keep
their kids unvaccinated
have you ever vaccinated your children I
haven't choice Lisa D Berg Otis has
three children all of them would have
been kicked out of school if the bill to
eliminate religious exemptions passed
while some religions do not object to
vaccinations others don't trust the
practice it's a big concern if people
are being harmed by vaccines that we
need I feel we need to just stop and
figure out what is going on because
there is no there's no proof that
they're safe but that assertion is not
backed by scientific study according to
the CDC major side effects of vaccines
are rare and there is no proof that
vaccines cause autism a common point of
misinformation the CDC also points to
the effectiveness of vaccines against
dangerous diseases for example two doses
of the measles mumps rubella vaccine is
97 percent effective against measles my
worry is that were trending the wrong
way we're going in the wrong direction
dr. Peter Hotez is an infectious
diseases specialist at Baylor College of
Medicine
he says epidemics like last year's
measles outbreak in which nearly 1300
people
were infected will become the new normal
as faith in vaccines
declines the fact now that we're seeing
children get sick hospitalized NICU
dying from vaccine preventable diseases
all because of a fake misinformation
campaign is very concerning New Jersey's
bill will go up for debate again in the
state Senate this week and it is
contentious one Democratic senator said
quote we're ready to go to war we will
pass this bill five states and ban
religious exemptions including New York
Maine West Virginia Mississippi and
California however Maine is trying to
repeal their band with a referendum of
this March the reason this is such a big
deal is because if enough kids do not
get vaccinated then the heard all of us
lose our immunity and the disease can
can can grow you know people forget that
before the polio vaccine this was a
deadly disease right who lost the
ability to walk people lost their lives
and that's just one example I mean
there's a long and positive history of
these vaccines helping kids and families
and as the doctors say this science is
clear I think thank you
you